we haven't even started yet but I gotta
tell you I really can use this coffee
right now
is it pica or FICA yeah this because
speak of me it means
[Music]
can I get the chicken salad I'll do the
egg salad half wait you have meatballs
too white so we've had a week of
rehearsals how are we feeling about
things I actually knock on what you're
surprisingly really relaxed and really
good about it
are you nervous that you feel relaxed I
know so there so now I'm thinking I'm
feeling so relaxed yeah what does that
mean yeah because it's not an
overconfident relax there's a difference
it's not an overconfident I said I feel
that this is such a seeming to me a
seamless transition cuz it's not like
we're new to each other that's the
beauty of it we're gonna be in the same
studio with the same crew who we are who
we know are top-notch we're changing
things up a little bit but maybe that's
why I feel so relaxed about it and and
most important of all it feels right and
that is a really good feeling yeah the
heartbeat of the show is the same and
we're essentially at our core were about
the same things we're about we're about
news yeah I know we're all committed to
making it work so I really do feel good
about it you know people haven't asked
me are you nervous are you nervous and
I'm trying to think should I say I'm
nervous
would that be better yeah you know are
you nervous no I'm not I've had the very
same question and I and I say you know
what I guess I should be but I know I
still feel like the news is gonna happen
the sun's gonna come up yeah and we're
gonna be ourselves and we know what our
mission what our mission should you
choose to accept it we know what the
mission is and we know that that mission
isn't really changing here so on that
mission there's really two kinds of news
right there's the news you you you can't
control you wake up something happen
overnight it's breaking and then there's
news that is gonna stay news for a long
time mm-hmm of those latter stories it's
the stories that we know are gonna be
big issues in 2020 what are you looking
forward to to covering all 24 candidates
let's put a pin in politics for a moment
they are there things happening in this
country right now that you know are
going to be happening over the next two
years you're looking forward to covering
this stuff that that I'm really
interested in this stuff that I think
isn't getting as much attention as it
actually deserves
which is there are huge technological
changes going on I mean all this people
sort of laugh about the whole the
driverless car thing look at that
constantly this is a country that where
the whole definition of freedom was was
built around the idea that you could sit
behind the steering wheel and go or
where you wanted to go you know my mom
one of my favorite songs of all time
Thunder Road talk about Thunder Road it
is one of my favorite interviews because
I love Bruce Springsteen where was home
home was right up here yeah he gives
very very very few interviews Anthony
Mason and I saw you with the black
leather jacket walking with Bruce
Springsteen and I went oh it was amazing
I like sitting down with somebody who's
done a lot of interviews yeah you you've
heard virtually everything you think
they're gonna say they're very good it's
spinning out of the personal questions
or they have a reputation that's really
well-established in public and and you
and you find a way to get past it even
though there are cameras even there are
cameras even there are lights it really
suddenly they all fall away it really
feels like there's an intimacy there and
and then a person opens up and the one
interview where that I felt that was
Greta Gerwig I remember at the UCLA
audition they didn't even look at me and
I thought that can't be a good sign
they don't let people in that they don't
look at me had a good time she had a
great time I loved that interview what
you were describing the sort of moments
of intimacy that you get which is what
I'm always trying to work for in an
interview is where you get something
that it feels genuine that's why always
fine guys politicians so hard yes
exactly it really all you want is just a
human connection a real moment yeah and
I find that to be very good yeah but to
me you're one of the best people at that
this is really the the first time I have
ever seen that picture and I would tell
you son your yearbook page governor well
is there anything else you could have
imagined doing with your life was there
a career that you left on the road side
to take this one I really want to be a
singer did you but I know I can't sing I
but my degree is in psychology so I
really thought that I would either be a
child psychologist because I love
listening people I can totally see that
and giving unsolicited advice I'm
feeling very good at that or being a
lawyer I just thought I saw myself in a
courtroom arguing a case so I thought I
would be happy with that but I fell into
this really by happenstance I was
working in a camera store and it was
next to a TV station and the news
director said hey you know you've got a
really nice voice
if you thought about TV well no and the
first time I walked in that newsroom and
saw breaking news but the people running
all around I just thought wow yeah and
I've never looked back after that do you
do either one of you remember my first
appearance on CBS I mean you know
obviously you do
spider-man paid a visit there's a guy
climbing at the side of Trump Tower with
suction cup hands Tony so he tosses to
me and I launch Scott for more than two
hours it's after about 10 seconds in and
then the producer off-camera yells no no
I stopped completely dead stop what
everyone am I you're saying no she's
saying go she's saying go there's been a
lag a delay yeah everybody in the
controller me ripping headsets off what
is going on what's wrong with him I came
back to the broadcast Center you know
and it in in in so many words I'm told
I'm not gonna be on the evening news for
many months turned out to be my favorite
mistake in journalism because as a
result of that I pitched stories to CTM
CBS this morning and a Sunday morning
and through those pitches I'm where I am
right now
yeah if not for that disaster I wouldn't
have sometimes it works out I think guys
even when it's a slow news day I'm never
bored yeah no I am never bored on this
job even when there's nothing going on
allegedly you can find something yeah I
mean the only limitation is your own
curiosity
and if you have curiosity about a lot of
things you can go anywhere curiosity
will make a make us a success then we're
in good shape